after 20 years of war america has gone
from bombing the taliban
to complementing them
i can tell you this though about what
the taliban has done they established a
firm perimeter outside of the airfield
to prevent people from coming on the
airfield during our departure and we've
worked that with them for a number of
days but they were actually very helpful
and useful to us as we close down
operations the u.s military released
this photo they say is the last u.s
commander on the ground at kabul airport
boarding the last u.s military flight
out of afghanistan
in the past two weeks since cabo fell to
the taliban
123 thousand civilians and 6 000 u.s
citizens have been evacuated making it
the largest mass evacuation undertaken
by the military in u.s history
secretary of state anthony blinken
estimated under 200 u.s citizens were
still in afghanistan who wanted to leave
but couldn't and called on the taliban
to live up to their pledge to allow them
to do so we will hold the taliban to its
pledge
to let people freely depart afghanistan
the taliban is committed to let anyone
with proper documents leave the country
in a safe and orderly manner
they said this privately and publicly
many times
lincoln indicated the u.s would keep
lines of communication open with the
taliban
but said it would do so from doha qatar
where the u.s would set up a diplomatic
mission to kabul
the u.s has ended its presence in
afghanistan but not necessarily its
involvement but what would future u.s
involvement in afghanistan look like
president joe biden is expected to
address that very issue in a speech on
tuesday
gabriel zondo al jazeera washington